the jurogan experience can i ask you how
you create a song like how when when
you're putting something like that
together
do you write it out on paper do you just
say it until you remember it like jay-z
apparently doesn't write anything right
right just keeps it all in his head do
you do that do you write it
when i first started out
my first album doggy style i got two
songs where i just freestyled one is
called g's and hustlers and one is
called the shiznit
those two songs i just went there and
just freestyle whatever came out of my
mind in my head of the day
i've been good at that for a long time
but a lot of times i like to make sure
that i'm pinpointing
a specific topic a specific cadence
and a specific style that i'm trying to
perfect
when i'm making a song i'm not just
trying to make
a record for the day i'm trying to make
something that's going to be here
tomorrow and the next day and the next
year
so when you said you freestyle it you
mean like when you walked in you really
didn't know what you were going to sing
when you were recording it well the song
the sharesnet
was supposed to be a mic check
i was supposed to go in there and just
check the mic
mic check one two might check it and
drake put the beat on
mic check check one two one two
hop and stop and hopping like a rabbit
when i take the nina rosh you know i
gots to have it i stay back in the cut
retain myself i'm thinking about the
[ __ ] and i'm thinking well how can i
makes my grip and how can i make that
[ __ ] straight slip said tripp gotta get
him for was grip as i dipped around the
corner now i'm on another mission
wishing upon a star it's snoop doggy dog
with the caviar in the back of the limo
no demo this is the real i'm breaking
[ __ ] down like evander holyfield chill
till the next episode i make money and i
really don't love hoes to tell you the
truth i swoop in the coop i used to look
man come on man
that was all the freestyle just going in
that [ __ ] just spit from the
dome and it just came out and dr dre
just made it wow
made it work
but every song is different
you know cause sometimes a song would
come to me
from just like hearing some [ __ ] or just
being out somewhere and be like damn i
want to make a song about
whatever i just went through or whatever
i'm going through or whatever
is the moment it's always a different
experience every time we make a song
so sometimes it's something that you
actually write out
a lot of times
the song murder was the case
i wrote that song
because i was
thinking about life after death
the song was initially called dave
d-a-v-e death after visualizing eternity
oh and
it was crazy that i was thinking of [ __ ]
like that and i had made a song called
murder was the case
that was about me
losing my life but before i lost my life
i didn't cut a deal with the devil but
then god came back and gave me another
chance
that was in my mind but when i wrote it
just became some gangster [ __ ] but that
was the premise behind it
and it was just in my head like i want
to write a song like this and then three
months later i caught a murder case in
real life
well yes so
my pen
was actually right in reality so i had
to pull back from certain things and say
maybe elijah started writing about life
and living instead of always writing
about dying and death
whoa
deep
just think about my peers me tupac
like just think about
our records
the last records that they made it was a
lot of death
it has some life in it too but
it had a lot of death in it
yeah that east coast west coast [ __ ]
it became a real
a real divide in the country with
hip-hop right yeah it was because you
didn't want to be on the wrong side and
you didn't want to like
like for example if you had friends
right that was leaning more towards the
east coast and you had a friend that
really wanted to hear west coast music
you all might have been to your
friendship yeah based off of that really
it was that serious yeah
how did it it went it kind of isn't that
way anymore though right
what it was
that's good isn't that like a good sign
for the future that's a great sign
there's people working together from all
parts of the world because like in the
90s that was a real problem that was a
real divide the divide was the we
couldn't control
the media like we can now
so even back then east coast and west
coast we used to hang with each other
and kick it and love each other but we
didn't control
the media platform so we we couldn't we
didn't have a instagram or facebook and
none of that [ __ ] where we can slap up a
picture of me and nas and jay-z and this
person hanging out we didn't have that
all you had was the media saying the
east coast and the west coast don't like
each other which side you're choosing
yeah and that's just that yeah
and
it's their job just to sell newspapers
right and then once lives were lost then
you could blame you can naturally say
tupac okay
did somebody have something to do with
that from the east coast we don't know
biggie he got killed on the west coast
that put speculation that maybe somebody
from the west coast has something to do
with it so i just kept fueling to the
fire until you had people like
uh puffy myself
steve harvey
who were man enough to say look we need
to put an end to this and let people
know
that we don't advocate that we really
love each other we're a family and we
started building bridges and started
doing things together and being seen
together and controlling our own
narrative as far as what we was putting
in the public's eye
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify